hey what's up folks welcome back to
GameSpot's stage here at e3 2016 I'm
delighted to be joined by the CEO
respawn entertainment mr. Vincent Paula
hey doin Vince I'm doing well dude
handshake Irene and maybe yeah you're
gonna die see were mimicking each other
with this III has been on for a couple
of days now so the two of us are a
little bit I mean you were up at a press
conference two days ago showing off time
force you time for two so you've had
interviews non-stop now right yeah it's
a we were just talking about it's really
weird for me because we the EA
playthings started on Sunday so we've
been doing demos and stuff sunday monday
today's the last day and now everyone's
just here all energized and would not
kind of like i'm really tired dog I
don't know what to do I feel like
there's been a Time Shift yeah
congratulations on enhancing titanfall
to a little bit of a squeaky leak just
before and then why not not too bad to
happen right before it was a few hours
before I know you know there was a lot
of buzz around it which is good no make
guess that means people wanted to see it
when it makes me happy so let's talk
about it I mean single player was always
the sort of the people result was
missing from the first game I mean
campaign multiplayer it worked in what
was the number it was number two most
played mode behind voltage oh hai bhai
attrition yeah out of how many modes um
I don't even know now with we added
right um and we took some way yeah so I
so people were playing it people played
it so you kind of solved the problem
which was the people who don't play
single player who only play multiplayer
I the people who play single player
never diving into the multiplayer so in
a way does it feel weird that now you
have a campaign because it seems to kind
of pay off yeah it's a little weird but
at the same time it kind of it brings
there are still a group of players that
they want that offline experience they
want to be able to play at their own
pace and you know as you get busier and
busier in life it makes sense you know
there's games or I'm like I play it in
30 minute chunks over the course of of
weeks so giving that experience to
players you know ultimately we spend
years of our lives pouring everything we
have into something yeah the more people
that can see it the better and I must
have been flattering that there was a
lot of people coming at a time for one
being okay you know what I like this
game for water days in terms of its
mechanics but there is a universe here
and I kind of want
no more about what's going on in it as I
must have felt good to go into titanfall
2 and be like okay here you go yes so in
terms of that story what are we looking
at where does titanfall tubes campaign
tour take place it takes place after
titanfall one it's not a direct sequel
so I think important to note is that you
don't you don't have to have played the
original you can pick this game up and
jump right into it it's fine which is
important especially since we're coming
to the ps4 now so there's no ice we have
all our xbox fans you know who we do
love we're not abandoning we love you
guys thank you for everything but now we
want to add more we want to add more
players to the mix so it was important
to make sure this thing was kind of
stand alone so the campaign takes place
after at some point after that there
will be some recurring characters but
it's not a direct sequel in that way
yeah you'll be filling in the blanks for
anyone's ever played it and so let's
talk about the Titans from what I've
seen I haven't played if my cursory
glimpses as a fan of the first game it
looks like the Titans are sort of their
more individualized they look like there
may be more powerful sort of in what
they do in terms of the other the Titans
the previous game is gonna be six new
ones as well can you speak to sort of
their abilities and their role within
the in the battlefield right so in the
previous game a Titan fight you kind of
go in you don't know what you're getting
is the loadouts change yeah in this game
they're all the Titans are very bespoke
so it's you know you go up against like
the two are selling today score can I on
score is you know flame based he's very
distinct when you see him off in the
distance you know you know there's a
visual cue of of I know what fight i'm
getting into him it's more like a kind
of like a street fighter approach where
you say right I know what I'm fighting I
can adjust my play style in this fight
now and go in and it's a more strategic
fight so it feels better okay so
presumably then there are some Titans
which are better against other Titans is
up or other tactics that you can employ
with cheating 01 yeah there's tactics
that you will comply differently based
on what you're fighting so you're trying
to get those Titan fights to maybe be a
little bit longer than they were in the
first game I mean so much of the first
game was you know trying to get like two
on one situations or you know trying to
sort of use the map to your advantage
are you are you trying to make a sort of
a fighting game elements thereof like
back and forth her not necessarily super
long
but we just want it to be more strategic
instead of just like I'm gonna run up
and we're gonna play Rock'em Sock'em
robots and you know until somebody dies
it's you know I can approach us a little
more smartly and maybe I can have an
advantage over you I can beat you must
be a design challenge and trying to
design another six Titans within this
game and have them be no like visit Lee
noticeable to have those cues yeah I
mean we have these so we have six new
ones but six total ok so the original
evolution these are the new Titans right
God but yes you know it's it's about
putting them new in there we have to
balance them you know visually so that
they're very distinct we have to balance
the gameplay we have to balance the
gameplay versus other Titans we have to
balance the gameplay versus pilots we
have to know so yes it's always a
delicate you know kind of dance and you
were careful in your messaging on the
first game to sort of not overload
gamers with all of the information
upfront about the various different
types so I kind of feel like maybe I'm
wandering into into an area of no
response but in terms of the soldiers
then the on foot action we've also seen
a bunch of unique abilities happening
there as well ki talked to some of those
abilities and and Arthur's class-based
or those pickups how is that working
there are more class base but you'll be
able to customize somewhat but like you
see we have the grappling hook in this
we use an ability you'll pick not
everyone has the grappling hooks okay so
you have to choose if you want to play
that and that adds to it just kind of a
natural extension in some ways of the
you know you can do the wall running the
double jumping the you know all this
vertical gameplay the grappling hook
just fits really nicely kind of into
that that whole system and then we have
other things like the blade where you
can kind of see and this affects your
team as well so now you take this you
throw it out there other people can see
where enemies are right it's what does
it feel like you guys were kind of first
ad to gauge with the player movement
thing like you were like okay you know
you have worked on some very prestigious
first-person games in the past you have
a new company you want to make a mark
titanfall was very much a new way of
playing first-person shooters and then
event you'd sort of saw call of duty end
up going that direction I mean we now
live in what we're talking about
grappling hooks and presumably you guys
have all this stuff done before
but now we're led looking in a world
where cliff Kosinski's games got a
grappling hook in it it's like quake 2
mod has come back all over I mean
overwatch as well what does it feel like
being sort of the you were the
harbingers of this new player movement
thing and we're enjoying this amazing
like first-person renaissance now yeah I
think it's a natural evolution of you
know as players get better they you know
they want something new and one of the
natural places to go is that movement
and kind of make it more free so i think
it's just you know i think it was bound
to happen yeah what's been like working
on the the campaign stuff as well has
the team of respawn grown have you sort
of i mean you're also working on a star
wars game as well don't that we've seen
it's very interesting and yeah have you
guys grown has it been good to get back
into that did you miss it because I mean
call of duty single players for years
the the best ones were ones that you
worked on so it must be fun to get back
into that it is fun to be able to kind
of tell the story different way and it
was you know we have a lot of designers
who have you know a lot of experience
kind of in Bryan telling these stories
so letting them you know go wild and
kind of make these snippets of things
that later ended up becoming pieces of
the game like new mechanics and things
that you'll only find in the
single-player and there's some amazing
pieces that you know I'd prefer people
not to know about them till the game
ships and right probably not really
likely to happen but the longer we can
keep it under wraps the better but
there's some just like amazing moments
where like we have some gameplay twists
that that I didn't necessarily expect
and write him we had some prototypes and
proof of concepts and they were just
fantastic and have you guys learned a
lot in terms of the sort of the map
design through doing your dlc stuff does
do the new sort of player movement
mechanics has that changed the way you
guys are approaching map design as well
because we're swinging a lot in the
trailer of like familiar stuff where
it's like oh yes okay windows place
beside walls the jump that way but is
there is there new sort of interesting
ways to move around those moms I think
we learned a lot just from you know
making the last game and seeing what
worked and then doing some DLC and
refining that even more so I think you
know designers we've got really good at
kind of making that those worlds work we
add new things like the grappling hook
you have to account for that and then
you know
make sure there's new ways to use that
that take advantage of it but at the
same time some people might not have it
mmm so you have to make sure it works on
on both levels you guys are coming out
in a pretty busy month as well I mean
was it march of 2014 was when titanfall
launched its right kind of in its own
little pocket it got a lot of like eyes
on it you're within a week now of a
battlefield and the last guardian the
Elder Scrolls is the same week infinite
warfare as a week afterwards is there a
worry that like all this first-person
nonsense is happening at the same time
and that you guys don't have that breath
of air you had last time I mean there
are people that you know they can't buy
every game right so they'll have to
choose so you know we hope they accuse
ours yeah you know the more games the
better for me I want to play him off so
what's it been like I guess we talked
about titanfall probably in the press as
always this you know we like to sort of
like say ok that was the narrative of
that game and titanfall when we I talked
to my peers here was a game that a lot
of us played very intensely for a month
or two months and it felt like there was
a drop off is that the case with users
on time for all so is that something you
particularly care about I mean holding
someone's attention for that long is
pretty good right it kind of goes both
ways if you can hold someone's attention
for a couple months that is pretty good
yeah but for a multiplayer game you know
you really want the longer you can keep
them the better you know you want that
player base to grow with you and you
kind of you know serve them new content
and then have a giant community around
you so I think we really did look at
that you know where there was more of a
drop off than we wanted on the last game
and we've addressed that with you know
kind of a deeper progression system and
and more mechanics i think it's a it's a
much more rounded gameplay experience
but you know it's okay we were able to
put the first game out there and then
learn from it and iterate on it and
improve things so you know it's easier
to do yeah coming around second time but
it's just it's such a but much better
more polished experience right even the
first game which you know we love it's a
huge success for us 12 million unique
players i mean that's you know that's
great on basically on a one platform and
xbox one in pcc as well and Microsoft
are doing this sort of cross by thing
play anywhere are you guys going to do
that with titanfall 2 on PC and Xbox
one or um probably not i think you have
to be a Windows 10 specific game and
right we're not so okay fair enough and
what's it like getting onto onto
playstation as well I mean was this
always the plan to sort of get the first
one hours you know you were a fledgling
studio again I mean you've got an
incredible amount of experience but it
was a new first person I p which is
never a surefire win and a new studio
you managed to do it was the plan all
ways to do ps4 and always to do a
campaign once you sort of have that win
behind you on the platform side we kind
of always assume we would you know
expand out the platforms and you want
more players we were going to launch on
xbox one you know just because it was
like you said we were a start-up and we
were able to focus on getting the
mechanics of the game right and not
worry about multiple platforms and you
know the bigger development side for
single-player we actually looked at it
for the first game and you know you look
at the problems that come with all this
extra movement how do you solve that and
how do you make the game fun and we
decided to focus the energy on
multiplayer and put the story elements
kind of in there and experiment with
something new and I think you know well
it went pretty well there's still a
limit of the number of people that that
want to play that right am I guess it's
it's it's interesting looking at the
first person space now because for years
it seemed like there was like not much
in terms of imagination and now we're
having this incredible Renaissance of
you know almost happening back to the
late 90s in terms of some of the
mechanics movement and why not and where
do you think titanfall to sort of
uniqueness comes from what is it that
you guys are doing that you don't see in
any of these other multiplayer shooters
or you know military shooters or like
that enough rest it's just about
creating experience that we love to play
and we think is great so i don't i don't
know i don't really look at it that way
necessarily i mean you always we play
other games and we see other games and
sometimes we're influenced you know and
things we should do or shouldn't do
based on what we say but ultimately it's
about creating an experience that that
we're proud of we have an amazing team
that you know works their ass off to
bring these things out and and if we're
proud of it
you know we hope other people will will
enjoy it as well cool i also want to get
your take on Scorpio and what Microsoft
are doing with their sort of split
generation are iterating within it
within a generation you've been around
the industry for a long time what is
your take on I do you think it'll be
easier easy for developers to do that as
it is for like scalability in pc or do
you see foresee problems for that are
you looking at titanfall 2 even with
that in mind we are I think you know
coming from a pc background in a lot of
ways I think you're used to that you
know kind of scaling things based on you
know people people have different
graphics cards or CPU power so it'll be
interesting to see if we get this you
know bringing more people in instead of
ending an era of one console and moving
on to the neck right you kind of leave a
bunch of people behind now it's you know
much like you do with the phone it's
like you know I get a new phone i give
the old one to my kids and i said are
you gonna give the old console to your
nephew or your you know it's it will it
expand out and bring more people in and
have give us more people to kind of
serve and i know hopefully that's the
case have you considering virtual
reality at all I mean you're coming out
on playstation 4 xbox one perhaps you're
doing something pc there's a million one
headsets do something you don't even
want to touch at the moment right now
we're focused on getting the game done
right you know so that's ultimately the
experience has to be good we've you know
teased around done some things where you
know like the game runs in VRE and
standing next to a titan as it's moving
around and seeing the scale is stunning
i think right now the movement in the
game is maybe not conducive to rice to
not vomiting okay yeah but you don't as
things get better and we see how people
solve problems I think there's going to
be some amazing advancements good stuff
we're excited to play titanfall 2 and
when when is it that when is it out or
not a lot platforms it's out on october
28 which i think is important because if
you saw our collectors edition this is a
wearable helmet okay i expect to see a
lot of a lot of pilots this halloween
awesome and it'll be on ps4 xbox one and
pc good stuff in some power thank you so
much for coming on gamespot stage always
a pleasure cool thank you very much for
watching we'll be back in a couple of
minutes we have a bunch of other
wonderful interviews coming up ed boon
is in the house for injustice to will be
out back in five minutes see you then
you